RETO MEIER: Today I learned
that when observed globally,
weather station records
show an increase
in average daily temperatures
of over half a degree
Celsius each decade
since the 1970s.
I'm Reto Meier, Google
developer advocate.
Join me as we explore
the NOAA weather data
sets with BigQuery.
Climate science can be
a controversial topic.
So when we told
Savio Lawrence we
were putting his
analysis on YouTube,
he asked us to
preserve his anonymity.
SAVIO LAWRENCE: You
just told them my name.
Am I in this shot?
RETO MEIER: It'll be fine.
We'll fix it in post.
So tell us, how did you go
about performing your analysis?
SAVIO LAWRENCE: So I found
the weather data already
present in BigQuery's
public data set project.
Then I used two great products--
BigQuery and Tableau-- together.
BigQuery includes two
weather station data
sets, the Global
Summary of Data, GSOD,
and Global Historical
Climatological Network, GHCN.
Basically, anyone
can add data to GSOD,
while GHCN observations are
subject to a common suit of QA
reviews.
I prepped and connected
this BigQuery data sources
to Tableau for
visualization and analysis.
The first thing I
noticed was a trend
of increasing
average temperatures
each decade for both data sets,
which led to further analysis.
RETO MEIER: Climate
science is complicated.
So let's dive into the
details of this analysis.
Many variables can
influence our results.
Our data sets are particularly
susceptible to bias
from the number of
stations reporting,
their relative locations,
and the frequency
of their observations.
For our analysis to be
meaningful, we start in 1973,
the year after
which there aren't
big jumps in the number
of reporting stations,
and there's a reasonable
global coverage of stations.
Our averages include
every station
with at least 300
measurements in a given year
to avoid seasonal bias.
This still only tells
us part of the story.
Global temperature
isn't consistent.
Some places may have gotten
warmer, and others cooler.
The distribution of
reporting stations
shows us that there are more
stations in the most heavily
populated latitudes.
As a result, the regions
with the most stations
will have a
disproportionate influence
on the overall climate trends.
To begin to account for this,
we can break our analysis
into smaller slices of the
data, based on latitude bands.
Stations here in
the Arctic Circle
show a significant increase
in average temperature
each decade--
1.23 degrees Celsius per decade
for GSOD, and 0.67 degrees
Celsius for GHCN.
The northern temperate zone
includes the largest number
of stations, and represents
the most highly populated zone.
As with the Arctic Circle,
both the GSOD and GHCN data
sets show a gradual increase
in the average temperature,
with 0.68 and 0.65
increases respectively.
When we reach the tropics
things get interesting.
These graphs show that
the average temperature
has remained fairly constant
across both data sets,
with an average increase
of 0.31 and 0.28
per decade in the
northern tropics,
and just 0.19 and 0.28
in the southern tropics.
Once we hit the
southern temperate zone,
both data sets saw a small but
gradual decrease each decade
until now.
Record temperatures
in 2015 and 2016
have largely erased the
drop since the 1970s.
Are the last two years
outliers, or the beginning
of a new warming trend for
the southern temperate zone?
It's too early to say based
on only two data points.
But it's an observation
worth tracking.
Finally, we reach the Antarctic,
where the number of stations
is extremely low compared to
the other latitude bands, which
creates a noisier data set.
The measurements we do have
indicate a significant cooling
trend each decade.
One possible influence could
be the increase in reporting
stations closer to
the South Pole that
have a lower temperature than
those located further out.
We can try to unwrap this
by further segmenting
the Antarctic Circle.
But for now, we'll add it
to the list of observations
that need more follow-up.
When measuring something as
complex as climate change,
it's important to
remember that there
are many variables that can
influence and bias our results.
So while making
observations is easy,
drawing conclusions isn't.
Analyzing raw data like this can
provide useful starting points
to form hypotheses, and
begin further investigations
into the broader trends
and potential causes
that they may represent.
As always, your first
terabyte of processing
each month is free.
So I invite you to
open up BigQuery,
and do your own analyses, and
share your results with us.
And as always,
subscribe to our channel
and follow our blog
to learn something
new every week with BigQuery.
SAVIO LAWRENCE:
You know, I think
it's OK if you just
tell people who I am.
I don't think this is
that controversial.
RETO MEIER: You're right.
Plus, we're safe
here in the bunker.
SAVIO LAWRENCE: Seriously, we
are in a bunker [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks for watching.
Click here to subscribe.
And be sure to check out
some other videos here.